there seems to be a growing Trend in
Hollywood now where there's a lot of
prominent product placement how do you
as a filmmaker feel about this growing
trend
[__] that's how I feel
total [__] [__] David one time
you said product placement is [__]
at the same thing it said even more than
that
at the same time you work to advertising
Gucci did you change your mind about
advertising last days no no I do
sometimes commercials to make money
but I always say every time I learn
something efficiency of saying something
and new technologies but product
placement in a film putrifies the
environment it's so absurd but it's
happening more and more what kind of a
world is this